merci beaucoup ludovic plus de 8 de
foucault en direct depuis antalya marc
bernier est avec nous également bonjour
à vous vous avez été ambassadeur de
l'union européenne en turquie entre 2006
et 2011 merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
l'invitation de france 24 marc pierini
il n'y a donc pas eu de cessez-le-feu ne
se dirigent manifestement pas vers une
trêve dans les heures à venir mais déjà
déjà la rencontre entre lavrov écoulée
bas aujourd'hui antalya risque déjà cela
représente un espoir
je dirais que tout effort de dialogue
est bon à prendre il n'y a pas de
résultat concret ce n'est pas très
étonnant on s'y attendait le ministre
turc des affaires étrangères l'a dit
ce que cette réunion confirme c'est
chose que l'on savait déjà mais qui sont
fondamentales 1 les décisions sont
prises au kremlin
deuxièmement la technique militaire qui
est utilisée c'est ce que j'appelle de
la méthodologie bosnie on rase tout en
désespère la population et on parle avec
ceux qui survivent c'est la même méthode
qui s'applique ici est par ailleurs vous
avez pu constater
dans le direct que vous avez fait de la
conférence de presse de sergueï lavrov
que vous avez une inversion complète de
la narration politique c'est à dire
c'est l'europe qui ont l'otan qui
menace la russie il n'y a pas de
d'invasion militaire il ya juste une
opération de sécurité on ne bombardent
pas des bâtiments civils etc etc donc ce
qui au final
transpire c'est que le discours
politique et militaire de la russie est
très peu crédible et c'est surtout que
nous avons aujourd'hui très peu de
visibilité sur la prochaine étape
qu'elle soit militaire ou diplomatique
mais l'important est peut-être ailleurs
vous évoquez l'instant ce discours un
militaire sur le front justement on a vu
coller les troupes russes avançait
lentement certains problèmes de
logistique avait été évoquée est ce
qu'on peut parler de défait de
défaillance d'erreurs stratégiques
commises par l'armée russe et est ce que
finalement cette lan torse mais pas l
occasion à saisir pour continuer et
tenter de trouver une issue à à 7 à ce
conflit à cette guerre est passée donc
par la voie diplomatique que lui propose
notamment la turquie par exemple
alors je dirais que les kremlinologues
les plus
aiguisées sont très sceptiques sur le
fait qu'on puisse faire changer d'avis
le président russe mais l'important
aujourd'hui c'est que effectivement
cette offensive unitaire est plus lente
que prévu ça c'est une chose très peu de
visibilité sur la réalité parce qu'il ya
bien sûr une guerre de l'information
vous le soulignez tous les jours dans
vos éditions mais je crois que
l'important c'est ce qui se passe cette
semaine regarder l'unité de l'europe
regardez dès cet après midi le conseil
européen à versailles avec des décisions
sur une meilleure autonomie énergétique
pas une indépendance complète de la
réussite mais un progrès considérable
qui nous coûtera cher l'hiver prochain
en se chauffera - mais on dépendra moins
de de la russie
regardez les décisions américaines
embargo complet sur le gaz et pétrole
plus facile pour les états unis que pour
l'europe regardez les vagues de
sanctions sanctions successives les
progrès sur la défense au niveau de
l'otan au niveau de l'union européenne
donc il ya énormément de choses qui se
passent qui auront des conséquences
durables au delà de l'horizon immédiate
qui est qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui sur
la russie on a l'impression qu'on tourne
la marque pyrénées justement vous disiez
à l'instant vous aviez parlé de
stratégie de grozny dans dans dans ce
que faisait là la russie en ce moment
même en ukraine tout ce que vous évoquez
à l'instant cette diplomatie de la
périphérie c'est train de sanctions
successifs ne suffiront pas à faire
plier le président russe
oui en effet c'est très difficile de
savoir qu'elle est
volonté ultime du président russe mais
ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui c'est que
le prestige qu'il pouvait y avoir ou la
crédibilité du système russe est en
chute libre qui aujourd'hui veut parler
au président russe il ya très peu de
gens il faut lui parler bien sûr mais il
ya peu d'espoir de lui faire changer
d'avis ce qui est aussi important c'est
que les sanctions actuelles qui ne vont
pas produire des effets du jour au
lendemain mais qui sur six mois ou un an
vont avoir des effets dévastateurs pour
l'économie russe représente
une décision politique sans précédent de
la part des pays occidentaux
et on voit bien à l'intérieur de
l'europe à l'intérieur de l'europe à la
fois au royaume uni mais aussi en france
en italie peut-être en gris
prochainement on voit une perte d'
influence politique de la russie
regardez comment le jour même de du
déclenchement de l'invasion en ukraine
trois candidats à l'élection
présidentielle française ont renversé à
180° leurs positions regardez comment un
leader de l'extrême droite italienne
s'est vu humilié en pologne 1 avec un
maire d'une ville qui ressort un tee
shirt qu'il portait il ya seulement
quelques mois à l'éffigie de vladimir
poutine donc c'est cette perte de
crédibilité est considérable et je
n'irai pas jusqu'à dire qu'il y avait un
modèle de gouvernance russe mais il y
avait quand même un système de
gouvernance russe c'est à dire on
muselle la presse on harcèle
l'opposition politique on harcèle la
société civile ont fait croire à son
opinion à toutes sortes de choses qui
sont parfaitement fausse et ça
ça n'a plus de valeur à l'extérieur ça
ne peut plus s'exporter et est donc ça
va créer des changements dans la vision
politique de certains partis à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne
cela pourrait créer des changements en
turquie parce que autant on doit
continuer à parler autant il ya des
intérêts commerciaux
et énergétique avec la russie otan leur
système de gouvernance tel qu'on le voit
à l'oeuvre depuis deux semaines n'a plus
de crédibilité un modèle qui s'effondre
donc merci beaucoup marc pierini merci
d'avoir pris le temps de nous répondre
d'avoir accepté l'invitation de france